bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag ce
mois ci nous allons parler dépenses
économie fiscalité investissements bref
nous allons parler budget et de son
impact sur le quotidien des saint
quentinois grands travaux gros événement
transport en vous dit tout
c'est parti
[Musique]
et
et pour commencer nous sommes nous allés
voir les saint quentinois afin qu'il
nous présente le budget pour
l'agglomération
je dirais dans les transports plutôt
infrastructures routières dans les
logements
si mon premier choix peut-être l'état
des routes ce tout ce qui est petit
enfance peut être social la culture sait
déjà c'est déjà pas mal
dans les loisirs etc on est assez bien
le tien moi je trouve déjà que le réseau
des médiathèques les extras des
investissements sur les pistes cyclables
qui soit plus sécure qui est des vrais
liaison parce qu'aujourd'hui et des
ruptures sans arrêt sur le chemin et
c'est dangereux dans l'innovation et
mais pas forcément innovations
techniques mais plutôt l'innovation
sociale et qui permettrait de t'être de
rapprocher les gens et maintenant le
budget voté par les douze communes qui
composent l'agglomération
un budget de transition depuis
l'élargissement en 2016
[Musique]
car nous sommes effectivement dans un
budget de transition tout simplement
parce que les choses prennent énormément
de temps quand on fusionne deux
intercommunalités qui n'avaient pas la
même histoire
c'est un budget de transition aussi
parce que nous sommes en train
d'intégrer les nouvelles compétences et
d'autre des nouvelles compétences qu'on
est intégrée au 1er janvier 2018
notamment les médiathèques et la voirie
d'intérêt communautaire
alors que nous n'avons pas les recettes
puisque les fameuses clay clé commission
locale d'évaluation des transferts de
charges n'ont pas été encore organisé et
le seront d'ici la fin de l'année
un budget de transition également avec
la suppression de l'amendement ex san
une suppression qui engendre un retour
au droit commun en matière de
participation au dispositif de
péréquation qui sera amorcée dès 2019
plus simplement
cela signifie que l'agglomération devra
trouver 13 millions d'euros échelonnés
sur cinq ans tout en continuant à
contribuer au redressement des finances
publiques
en plus d'eux
d'un fonctionnement de tous les services
qui s'améliore on est on essaie
d'améliorer la qualité de service et la
rapidité de ce service à la réactivité
de ce service où les communes blessures
sont leur niveau d'exigence et c'est
normal
donc oui on est quand même dans toujours
un peu ce grand mukoko que tout le monde
connaît mais c'est effectivement faire
mieux avec moi on est confronté à cela
pour l'instant réussi le désendettement
se poursuit malgré les mauvaises
nouvelles comme je voulais dit un budget
de plus en plus tendue par les baisses
de dotations et des augmentations de la
péréquation nous sommes aujourd'hui
encore à 337 millions
d'investissement ce qui est tout à fait
acceptable au regard de nos recettes de
fonctionnement de notre capacité de
désendettement 55 millions de
désendettement depuis 2014 ce qui permet
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'être notée
double à par l' agence standard and
poor's et permet également de ne pas
augmenter la fiscalité pour les
contribuables comme pour les entreprises
là c'est une volonté qui est très
importante et notamment du président de
saint quentin en yvelines jean michel
fourgous de ne pas augmenter la
fiscalité est donc de préserver le
pouvoir d'achat des saint quentinois
[Musique]
malgré ce budget de transition et les
contraintes l'investissement demeure la
priorité des territoires saint
quentinois pas question dé renoncer ceci
pour développer l'économie et les
emplois de demain est resté attractif en
2018 l'investissement est maintenu avec
une augmentation de 5 millions d'euros
par rapport à 2010 cette réfection de la
voirie entretien des espaces verts
gestion des équipements culturels et
sportifs collecte et traitement des
déchets l'agglomération garde le cap
nous avons regardé quels étaient nos
marges budgétaires nous avons estimé que
nous pouvions sur les trois prochaines
années
engagé aux environs de 140 millions
d'investissements et nous avons
travaillé avec l'ensemble des maires et
des services pour trouver vraiment les
projets qui étaient prioritaires à
l'échelle de notre territoire
il y a des très beaux projets comme
l'éducation du futur ça commence bien
sûr l'école du futur ça commence à saint
quentin
l'écho les plus performantes interne
numérique et ça va jusqu'à l'université
du futur
la future université paris saclay on va
lancer en 1er janvier 2020 qui sera la
première université française donc oui
la tourne toujours un pôle très fort
dans l'innovation dans une nouvelle
méthode d'apprentissage pédagogique les
très belles entreprises qui travaillent
bien sûr sur l'intelligence artificielle
on est aujourd'hui la paix la première
plateforme française de recherche
intelligence artificielle à saint
quentin en plus on a cette culture de
l'innovation et ça correspond bien aux
besoins de demain de nos de nos citoyens
dont peillon prépare vraiment la ville
de demain ici et puis la vie à vider les
aspirations que nos administrés ont pour
mieux vivre demain saint quentin en
yvelines a fait le choix de développer
une ville intelligente au service de ses
habitants
les transports sont ainsi facilité via
une application diffusant une
information multimodale en temps réel
[Musique]
côté éclairage public un schéma
directeur d'aménagement de lumière
permet une gestion optimisée la
domotique
elle rend possible le maintien à
domicile des seniors une solution
développée au mais rente ai à magny les
hameaux
côté culture les médiathèques de plaisir
les clayes-sous-bois villepreux et
maurepas ont rejoint le réseau saint
quentinois au 1er janvier dernier
c'est le premier réseau de lecture
publique de la région pour une offre
améliorée 2018 c'est aussi la poursuite
des grands travaux comme ici le
doublement du congrès schuller entre
maurepas et la verrière ou encore
enfouissement de la rn10 à la trappe
on fait le tour
[Musique]
entre la gare de la verrière et maurepas
les travaux se poursuivent
des travaux qui engendreront le
doublement du pont guy schuller le but
fluidifier le trafic
créer un nouvel axe de circulation douce
améliorer l'accès de l'ensemble des
usagers à la gare mais aussi sécuriser
le franchissement de la rn 10 après la
pose des fondations en 2017
le tablier est actuellement en cours de
réalisation
[Musique]
quant aux prochains travaux
d'enfouissement de la rn10 attrape le
dévoiement des réseaux relève de la
compétence de l'agglomération les
territoires interviendra sur le réseau
d'assainissement à montigny le
bretonneux des buttes antibruit
devraient être réalisés aux abords de la
12 dans le quartier du pas du lac
ceci afin d'atténuer les nuisances
sonores d'autres travaux sont à l'oeuvre
comme la rénovation des réseaux
d'assainissement d'éclairage public et
de réfection de la voirie à elancourt la
rénovation du réseau d'eau pluviale et
d'éclairage public à maurepas
le réaménagement du parvis de la gare
plaisir les clés du carrefour de
l'avenue léon blum et de la rue guy
mocquet de plus l'agglomération a confié
à la safer la valorisation du site de la
ferme de bus loyer à magny les hameaux
afin notamment d favoriser l'agriculture
périurbaine l'attractivité des
territoires passe aussi par les grands
événements sportifs en septembre
prochain à l'agglomération organisera à
la ryder cup de golf le vélodrome a
quant à lui accueilli plusieurs
championnats internationaux depuis sa
création est certes un lieu saint
quentinois ont été retenu comme site
olympique pour les jo 2024
les grands événements sportifs font
partie du décor saint quentinois
en l'espace de quatre ans le vélodrome
nationale a accueilli les plus grands
championnats mondiaux
les championnats du monde sur piste en
2015 les championnats de france de judo
en 2017
la coupe d'europe de handball et la
coupe du monde de bmx en 2018 entre
autres
[Musique]
en septembre prochain le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
la ryder cup de golf
le troisième rendez vous sportif le plus
médiatisé au monde à la clé un
rayonnement mondial et de retombées
économiques considérables pour
l'agglomération en 2024 certaines
épreuves des jeux olympiques se
dérouleront en fait le drôle de saint
quentin en yvelines ou encore sur la
colline d'elancourt pour cela
l'extension de la ligne 18 jusqu'à la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines est
particulièrement attendu sur le plan de
la gestion on est bon on le voit sur les
notations que nous avons sur le plan du
développement économique
on a quasiment doublé les résultats de
2016 et 2017
sur le plan du pôle éducatif on est en
train de monter en puissance sur le plan
du pôle sportif vous avez les événements
mais sur aussi
gio que 4 sites olympiques que la ryder
cup sont des événements dimension
mondiale nous à un pôle culturel aussi
continuer à fonctionner bien là que tout
aussi qu'on fait bouger et transporte
bien entendu où on a débloqué beaucoup
de dossiers pour augmenter sur la
fluidité et ce fameux grand projet sur
lequel on en train d'étudier et qui
effectivement si ça marche ça peut
effectivement résoudre beaucoup de
problèmes pour pour beaucoup de monde et
aide encore un peu plus dans la
modernité
patience donc 2018 réserve encore des
surprises aux saint quentinois à très
bientôt
ciao
[Musique]